alright I'm on with Ferren in Canada
Theron how are you I'm good time tiny
danger I'm doing well I've been enjoying
talking to all these great people so
what's going on up in Canada these days
how's Canada Oh Canada is fine
not as libertarian-leaning as I'd like
myself but I'm working on it I I work
with an organization called students for
liberty and I'm currently going through
training to be kind of in charge of the
Canada set of students for liberty sir
working towards liberty yeah yeah well
as you know I've kind of been into
libertarianism lately I think it's very
close to classic liberalism which is
really where I consider myself but
speaking of your political leanings my
producer told me just a minute before we
connected that apparently you're in
Breitbart
related to something about my low just
this morning so can you tell me what it
is he literally just screamed something
in my ear then ran off
sure well the the name of the articles
like it's called [ __ ] for Trump and
it's basically talking about trans woman
who even like Donald Trump will support
him fully I don't fully support him but
I like him in many ways and I think his
presidency could in some ways actually
be helpful yeah but that's a strange
place to be for a libertarian right
because he seems to be a big government
more of a liberal guy but I think you
like the you like the sort of trolling
on political correct idea I don't agree
with his trade policies I think that
they're economically illiterate I don't
have a particularly strong stance on his
immigration policies
yeah sorry no I don't really like that
and I read an article just the other day
that if he comes in his president if he
becomes president that things like taxes
would be risen and minimum wage would so
not
not much it's a strange place for a
libertarian I like yeah alright so you
gave me a lot on your on your email
entries so let's let's dive right into
it so first off you're a men's rights
activist correct yes so can you explain
what that means because I think a
certain set of people get that and then
another set think that something crazy
and then but I think the bulk of people
just don't even understand what that
means
mm-hmm so a lot of people don't
necessarily realize they are informed
about the fact that men are falling
behind or discriminated against in many
ways in today's society in in Canada in
America where there is the high suicide
rates whether it's the high rates of
homelessness whether it's you know men
kind of getting the short end of the
stick
legally nowadays with all these rape
cases and and then this domestic
violence which is also a huge problem
and men really don't get seen and the
statistics and the knowledge on the true
the reality of domestic violence isn't
really isn't really known to most people
so I am I'm not an I'm more than just an
act
advocate I'm an activist I need a man's
rights group on my campus at Simon
Fraser University and we host monthly
events inviting different people with
different perspectives on men's issues
we had Karen stron and Alison teaming
last month and they have this coming up
month we're having a panel discussion
event on different perspective of
masculinity from men going on their own
way to mythopoetic which you probably
don't know if you're not into the men's
movement and in this fact the feminist
perspective so we're gonna have a whole
panel discussion so it's really about
boots on the ground activism and really
engaging with people so I'm kind of
taking the online I'm one of the people
taking on lines fail offline and trying
to raise awareness one on one yeah so I
think for the average person watching
this that doesn't know much about these
issues they're probably looking
you in saying wait a minute here's a
trans woman into men's rights issues
that kind of flips everything on its
head does that give you a certain cachet
within the community I think that it
gives me a lot of freedom to say what is
true without being labeled misogynist or
a sexist or this or that I said a lot of
things that if some average white guy
said it he would be maligned I think my
being trans has helped a lot for our
club in the sense that we haven't been
protested much we have while we haven't
purchased it at all we haven't got too
much backlash and I think it's because
in the kind of regressive mindsets
attacking a group that's led by what is
in their minds an oppressed minority
would be oppressing a minority yeah so
you're sort of like kryptonite in a way
to them and because because they judge
you not by your individual ideas right
but they're judging you as solely a
trans person they know the trans person
is high on the oppression Olympic cart
so then they can't really figure out how
to attack you thus you're able to
protect your own ideas I mean it's it's
actually kind of genius and also bonkers
well well it's genius
and yes bonkers I kind of realized that
very early on I realized when I realized
the the reality of men's issues and how
there isn't much a lot of sparks people
for men and men who suffer I realized
that if if not me who you know and who
better than a trans woman I realized
right away the position I'm in and how I
would be squandering a really great
opportunity so I totally I try to use my
identities a trans woman to further
men's rights and I'm not really ashamed
of it because I want to help men and I
want to further their discretion yeah so
obviously I get the part that you've
sort of insulated yourself from some of
the criticism but when you do get the
criticism it does it feel particularly
purse
to you because you're trans and that I
talked to another trans person that's
sort of like the thing of the moment no
no I I don't know I criticism I get from
kind of the regressive side I don't know
it they don't generally try to really
steer away from the fact that I'm trans
a lot of them the criticism that has
been like lodged at our club haven't
even recognized me as the president they
kind of tried that I wouldn't touch with
a ten-foot pole I mean I get criticism
for being a female men's rights activist
in general I mean there are a lot of
people could take issue with that it's
just kind of a pitch wedding you know
everyone focusing on women you know are
there other women in the group yes it's
actually our executive team is three
women and one guy I mean that's really
fascinating yeah I find women a lot it's
a lot easier for them to approach let's
say we're tabling at Club des it's so
much easier for them to approach our
table and start discussing and they
don't fear I find a lot of men are kind
of kind of weary they're very afraid
that they're gonna be judged as a
certain you know they're gonna be judged
as misogynistic or sexist or why are you
why are you so shooting with those
people so yeah it's actually quite a bit
easier to to attract women but then when
I hear about the men who are who do come
talk to us the men who kind of muster up
the bribery I hear like horrible stories
you know from being you know horribly
abused by their girlfriends all having
narcissistic mothers and these two
fathers then I'm just I hear I hear
really the truth for what's going on and
yeah I would encourage men to
to come to approach us more because we
are an accent kind of a safe space if
you want a space is right I like I don't
like sex spaces if that means that you
can't talk about certain things but
that's not really what it means in our
context it more means that we won't
malign you if you feel certain ways if
you feel angry because a lot of men are
angry and I understand that anger I'm
not gonna tell them that they're just
misogynists and sexist they're not gonna
get judged they're gonna have at least
an understanding yeah yeah so it's not
it's not a safe space of ideas it's just
a safe space of judgement which are two
different things it's an understanding
compassionate space how about that yeah
so what's what's next after this so you
know when you get out of school is this
something that you want to pursue at a
career level or are you interested in
other things altogether well I'm
currently finishing up my music
composition degree which is completely
kind of separate from what I'm doing
here but I actually want to go into law
and probably constitutional law but I
think in in my patent law I can
definitely influence some real at least
legal change where it helps men but also
just defending constitutional rights and
you know human rights on a very basic
level and kind of putting my effort into
keeping this state small yeah that's the
libertarian part there you go well
listen we could obviously do a lot more
but unfortunately we got a we got to cut
it short so I really enjoyed talking to
you and good luck with everything I
enjoyed talking to you as well thank you
so much for the opportunity Dyer
alright I'm on with Tomi from the UK
Tomi has it gone very good thank you
very much how are you I'm doing well so
your story you know everyone's sending
me these great sort of life stories and
what they want to talk about there was
something particularly interesting right
at the beginning of yours you're
originally from Nigeria and you moved to
the UK the day before 9/11 so you moved
on
September 10th 2001 can you describe a
little bit of that yeah um when I first
got the the news about that I was a
topical double-decker you know the sort
of British buses sure but a to stage the
to your level bus is out the top of that
and that's when we heard the news about
that something is happened in New York
and you know some explosion of something
about buildings and then we go home and
then I sort of saw the pictures about
what happened and you know it didn't I
didn't really understand the gravity of
what had happened I mean I understood it
was you know horrible thing and many
people died but it wasn't years so years
later died sort of really understood
like you know the world has changed in
in a radical way so that was sort of my
my earliest memory coming into the UK
I'm so you know sort of a baptismal you
know yeah I yeah talk about a crazy time
to move to the West so let's back up a
little bit
tell me a little bit about growing up in
Nigeria what what kind of family you
came from and what made you guys move to
the UK or do or did you move by yourself
um actually I'm not sure no I I moved I
moved my father my mom my mom my mother
is a nurse she wasn't as many as a
Nigeria I'm gonna say she because
there's a you you do know we have an NHS
here and there's a high demand for
nurses in the UK and so she moved over
to the UK about two years before we
moved to join her on my father was a
journalism used to be an editor in oil
and gas magazine in Nigeria so we moved
together myself my younger brother would
move together with him um and we move
basically essentially so you have a
better education in the UK I meant with
our mother and so that was you know a
little bit yes yeah what was life like
in Nigeria people you know you hear
about Nigeria but we don't know really
at least here in the West or in the u.s.
we don't talk about Nigeria that much
tell me a little bit about what it was
like growing up in Nigeria life was fun
you know you out there your friends
plane it was you know child childhood it
was the best time you know it was just
no care in the world
yeah all during the time when I was
going
growing up in Andhra we had a dictator
general Sonia bachi and he was a very
ruthless guy you know destroyed the
country in a lot of ways economically
embezzled a lot of money but mines
earrings are very resilient they are
probably the most resilient people in
the world it you know you you put them
you know in the middle of the Sahara
Desert it starts any Elise and she is
very resilient so we got through we
survived we did well you know went to
school and things like that
but so was meaning coming towards the
time I was coming to the UK he passed
away and there was massive parties in
the streets and everything like that so
now oh yeah say that's that's how much
hated he was and then did another
dictator come in right after him I don't
even know after that we had a civilian
we had our first democracy after many
years of going through generals and
dictators basically and so we had a
passenger who became president and he
ruled boy he was also corrupt in many
ways and and he's also from the same
tribe that I am in Nigeria bought many
from my partner especially my dad did
not like him because it was not a fair
man so we had that but now we we're a
country struggling a lot we just had our
our presidents come to the UK for some
anti-corruption talks and he's trying to
get back some money because the country
has been really hammered by my previous
regimes basically yeah all right so
let's flash forward to today one of the
things that you wanted to talk to me
about is something that we've touched on
the show on of just a tiny bit but brags
it it's obviously huge for you guys over
there now you support brexit right yes I
am a big supporter of Brick City I'm a
big supporter of Britain as an intern
I'm a big supporter as a first
generation immigrant and I'm weak
support of President citizen and it's it
rests essentially on this principle I
asked myself this question if I was an
eye injury and I found that that the the
Nigeria spa litical system was
controlled by another political system
that was based in Cairo
that's in Egypt and they made the passed
our laws they told us what to do with
our fishes and in our waters and all
that kind of stuff I'd be upset about
that I'll say that's it that's not fair
we can't Nigeria should have control
over their own laws and over their own
borders and everything so I look at it
from our point of view he's also
Nigerian live in the Niger and this was
happens in I'm sure how would I feel and
take it to the UK now that is that is
exactly what is happening to the UK we
have a situation whereby we have our
European Commission that is not elected
or passes the law that we have to buy to
and we cannot vote them out of office so
it's essentially a sort of a dictatorial
system of sorts yeah so how much of your
feelings about that is fuelled by just
the border situation because one of the
things I think we've done about 12
interviews now and one of the things
that almost everyone has wanted to talk
to me about in Europe is the immigration
stuff and the border stuff and the
migrant stuff and all that so how much
of your feeling is just wrapped up just
in that you want the UK to be able to
control its own borders I think that's I
think that's an e I think that's a very
essential part of of the brexit argument
but the border the border situation is
tangential to the real issue and I guess
since I'm not an indigenous British um
the way I feel about immigration might
be slightly different but I have a lot
of sympathy to indigenous to the
indigenous boy who are saying that if
they feel the sense that the country has
been overwhelmed and they have no
control over it so I have an
appreciation and I sympathize with that
all right my biggest problem is that if
we do not give nations control of the
over their borders it will lead to a
situation of social tensions and as
someone who is an immigrant and you know
I'm black you know in case you don't
know as someone who is an immigrant I
feel like if you create so much social
tension within the system if there'll be
a backlash and so my biggest worry about
this whole EU control Anu the control
the he puts on different nations is that
it
doesn't allow nations to act
autonomously say it doesn't give them
that sort of self will teach to do
things in that list of frustration and
that's what we see the rise of the far
right and the far left in Europe now
yeah so I'm curious so as a
first-generation immigrant it's really
interesting you're you're framing this
not only from your perspective but you
are looking at the people that live
there before you and sit saying that
they have some legitimate fears or maybe
some of it's not fully legitimate but
you're acknowledging it I'm curious has
some of the sort of regressive ideology
has that affected you in that I think
most people would probably look at you
and say that you're black and that
you're an immigrant and that you should
be for fully open borders or something
along those lines
III like to say it is I'm a fair-minded
person and I
I also like to deal with the realities
of life so about 90 away I'm from in
late 80s we had a massive immigration
from Ghana which is another West African
nation into Nigeria because the other
economic downturn bought that put a lot
of pressure on on jobs and services in
Nigeria and they became this chance you
know this this movement called
god-honest go now that wasn't a sort of
a racist movement but in that I could
see in appreciate that whenever you have
a massive influx of immigration
uncontrolled immigration it's another
place it leads to social tensions and
you can look at it throughout history
and throughout everywhere in the world
and so we have to do with this fairly
ami I'm Pro immigration immigration is
good when it has to be controlled it has
to be sensible and it has to be at the
behest and at the will of the people if
not it's gonna lead to trouble and and
that's that's where I think this
discussion needs to be to be hit hard
man you're talking a lot of sense why
aren't you on TV over there you know I
don't speak a lot of PC stuff so I'm
back on that note I'm gonna let you go
without saying anything I'm gonna let
you go without saying anything too crazy
it was really was a pleasure talking to
you all right I am on with Marcelo who
is in May
in the United States via Brazil am I
correct yes you're right and from Rio de
Janeiro Brazil that is quite a move to
go from Brazil it's hot and now cold
what people are supposed to go the other
way what are you thinking yeah I
actually lived before in Connecticut
initially when it moved to us then lived
a little one year in Miami so I kind of
experience the warm back and now I'm
back you mean it was just mostly for my
work right what kind of work do you do
I'm a physician right right okay we're
gonna get into a little bit of that I
knew that actually but so one of the
things that you wanted to discuss with
me was how regressive attitudes and this
ideology had really infected Brazil and
how you saw it change attitudes in
Brazil so can you tell me a little bit
about that yeah
Brazil overall is a pretty hardcore left
leftist country the culture in Brazil
was taken over by hardcore socialists in
less about 30 years they took over the
churches the the press the universities
and they they have this mindset of not
wanting to debate ideas so the way that
they see things is that if you're not if
you do not agree with them then you
should shut up you should basically get
out of the way and this is quite
concerning because you see people who
have this will to learn and to get into
debate and you know and I think that's
how countries progress that's how ideas
debating ideas that's how you get to a
common stance so a place for everyone
and when you can my language brother
there you go
and that's actually what caught me to
your show initially this idea of
fighting for free speech and in Brazil
basically there was killed and now in LA
in less 10 years I would say there is a
conservative movement surging it's too
small
asou not in power but at least in it
there is another way of thinking kind of
surging and people are interested people
are actually looking to it and
whoa this exists you know like oh that
makes sense and that's very interesting
and it's very unfortunately the person
who entered that what direction so
that's really fascinating so you're
saying basically in the last ten years
as a result of this regressive ideology
taking root that now conservatism is
bubbling up and that is what is
defending free speech it sounds a little
backwards for the way America is
although right now I see that happening
here because strangely it's
conservatives that are defending free
speech and the left that's trying to
stifle it so it's really everything's
kind of upside down yeah I totally agree
with you and I'm not sure if there's a
direct effect of that or if it's just
people really when you read about new
ideas they get interested even if they
don't agree initially when they've had
the freedom to do it they so there are
some thinkers some writers in Brazil
that 10 years ago started writing some
stuff and that's when actually I start
reading more about conservatism more
about America the free speech ideas the
the individual rights and the Indy idea
of you're able to see whatever you want
and you're fine if you don't like it
that's fine that's fine I like it and
and there's not the way in Brazil before
and if I saw for example journalists
actually I'm having to move away from
Brazil in order to be able to speak and
that's that for me it's something
unacceptable you shouldn't have yeah I
have to say that until I read your email
I really didn't realize how bad things
had been in Brazil so one of the things
that you wrote that was interesting is
that you started getting interested in
conservative writers and that sort of
helped your awakening and now you're
saying many years later these
conservative ideas are becoming cool
again down there who are some of the
writers that you are interested in well
any choice are reading Brazilian writers
and one of them was a philosopher called
Bolivar de Carvalho he currently lives
in Virginia he's well-known philosopher
well-known writer in Brazil who actually
had to move away he's one of them and he
lives in Virginia u.s. he's a big fire
against communism against socialism in
Brazil
speech for free speech guy after started
reading his stuff I then start reading
American writers like Thomas all Henry
Hazlitt and von mises other guys from
other countries as well Oh mrs. and from
of the Chicago School Milton Friedman
more recently I've been reading a lot of
things that Dinesh D'Souza writes so
there are a few conservatives and they
usually these guys they defend free
speech so you find a free extender buy
ideas and some of them were actually
leftist before like David Horowitz was a
hardcore laughs laughs exists yeah
Thomas always a leftist and they when
they got in contact with the ideas of
conservatives they they kind of Linda
the other direction yeah I've really
been doing my best to get Thomas soul on
the show I don't I don't know how much
public stuff he does anymore but I'm
working on it so stay tuned on that one
okay so you move up here and you've
already seen the damage that these
ideologies have done in your home
country so what do you make of what
they're doing to America right now it's
like seeing a movie again and and it
actually changed a lot I feel like it
change a lot in the last let's say eight
years seven years since I moved not sure
why but I see happening things that I
never thought it would be possible here
when I moved to America I thought you
know the universities here are the best
universities in the world they probably
have very free environment for new ideas
for speech for debate and then when we
see cases like Miss Mizzou where the the
professor was saying get some muscle
here to shut off a student a student
yeah and then you see guys that should
just to stay with guys that you need to
review their Shapiro's mile being well
there was violence against them and and
they cannot even speak in in warning
campuses and you're see left is even
leftist powers one of the journalists
wrote a book about the left shutting out
Oh Christina powers I've seen a powers
yeah so even those guys people are wait
wait this is not cool just not nice it's
not good for anybody
yeah so what do you do
in your own personal life to combat this
stuff I guess this is the example of it
right here you're talking to me so that
so that's pretty good but really as
someone that has seen the damage of this
and you see this happening now is there
I mean do you post stuff on Facebook the
try to get stuff out there to combat
some of this yeah I use my facebook a
lot I have a lot of American friends
that have resident friends
I'm very political Facebook I'm glad
that I still live in a country that is
very free that I'm not afraid like I was
in Brazil people in Brazil are afraid of
speaking out things against the
government for example yeah here no I
feel comfortable so I'm very I'm very
active Facebook and I usually try to use
the experience that I have in pursue and
you know close to my American friends so
they can see the parallel you know like
to try to avoid it would be horrible to
see America go in the directions all
right do you have American friends that
are defending you yet and blocking you
and all that maybe in some cases you
wouldn't know right okay so the other
thing let's move away from politics a
little bit although everything is
political so you mentioned that you're a
physician and one of the things that you
wanted to talk about was the free market
and healthcare I don't have a ton of
time left but can you just go with that
tell me yeah basically just a short
thing in Brazil we have free health care
meaning the government takes over
everything and that's where exactly
where I see people dying for lack of
basic care people waiting lines for six
months to get an MRI when they have
cancer they timeline that's very common
and I believe that as anything else in
life when the free market is able to
should work it works better than the
government so I think in that sense
where you're going the wrong direction
we America has a very good health care
we have problems that can be solved we
have to sit down and see what the best
policies to get but the I think the
fundamental idea is that we should go
towards more free market because
competition makes prices go down makes
things more available services more
available
I want a system that gives us iPhone new
TVs new cars for cheap I don't want a
system where you give my healthcare to
spend 1 billion dollars to make a
website that doesn't work right so for
you in the in the personal sense as a
physician how have you seen the
healthcare economy change in the I mean
it's obviously changed hugely in the
last three years alone what have you
seen firsthand well I work in the
hospital but here I think the hospital
haven't we had the heat from Obamacare
yet but I see a lot of people who work
as an office outside with patients
scheduled outpatient retiring because
they just can't handle anymore I see a
lot of regulations coming in increasing
the prices because every single
regulation every single pile of new
rules costs so when you when you get
more government in between patients and
physicians you have bureaucracy you have
more costs so prices go up and I've been
seeing this and we don't have the
Obamacare fully implemented yet I think
there are more things to come and then
make maybe make things are going worse
listen if I ever need a full frontal
lobotomy because of the regressives is
that something you can do very good
fighter for freedom we need you all
right fair enough we'll listen it was a
pleasure talking to you I wish we had
more time but we got to keep going was
my pleasure thank you so much for
letting me participate in your show all
right I'm talking with you from
Switzerland how's it going I'm pretty
fine yeah I'm fantastic actually thanks
for having me good that seems like the
answer that someone from Switzerland
would give I'm pretty fantastic people
think everything's great over there huh
well life here is actually pretty great
so yeah everybody's happy around you
know we need to show that you know I
like hearing that because you know we
talk about a lot of heavy stuff on the
show but it's nice to know that things
are working but one of the things that
you mentioned you want to talk about is
the dreaded regressive left and how
their ideology is changing society in
Switzerland so go ahead well all the
equivalent of them yeah they're not
really out there in your face like in
other countries but that actually speak
volumes
I mean they've always been there but
yeah and they keep on stirring the pot
you know I mean we recently had a case
like in tabby that's just around the
corner from my alley in which you know
two boys from a school from Syria with a
very strong religious background refused
to shake hands with FEMA teacher yeah
yeah yeah that made news here yeah and
you know the reason behind that was
because they didn't want to study her
dignities by touching her right and this
of course all stemmed from the father
who is preaching at a local mosque and
yeah this stood quite controversy here
and you know and of course you know the
reactions were huge you know I mean we
have to ride shouting all the way down
there it's not acceptable and the other
idea and you had left I'm playing
everything down saying like you know
it's just a hand shouldn't you know if
you want to go and do some heretics you
can go to the street and do that it's
not big of a deal at all and most of all
they all kept on saying stand against
Lois it's fine right but I think what
annoys people more and the reason why
they're so there were so passionate
about the whole ordeal was because um
the decision of the school by just I'm
tolerating that without actually any
article to know which is quite a
regressive thing to do you know and you
know of course concerns remained you
know by the people because the night and
they want to start a scope discussion no
it's not particularly about the
handshake itself which also refused the
moderates in our country and they're
just asked themselves stuck they wanted
to start the question you know like what
is them acceptable in terms of
integration mm-hmm what is acceptable in
tombstone which is freedom you know and
this basic s been washed out by just
saying like the last thing like you know
it's not a big deal you know it's just a
sorry
and it also interviewed them the head
teacher from the school and he also kept
on saying it's not against the rules and
that's about it
colleges don't want to put ourselves out
there too much you know and this annoyed
quite a lot of people because you know
the reason why they feel passion about
the school or
deal was not because you know a
handshake itself is because the
discussion which has never been actually
made no this was kind of a big deal here
rounds yes so it's not about the actual
handshake nobody really cares about that
but it's just about the creeping idea
behind it which is that that these boys
will grow up and not necessarily respect
women or treat women as equals and then
that becomes an actual societal problem
so it's not about a bunch of young boys
whether they shake this one person's
hand or not well I think it's it was
more about like no we just want to talk
about that and we don't actually want to
talk too much into the future because we
don't know what actually would happen
you know it was just like let's just
talk about it and at some point it was
just not possible anymore and it didn't
end at that point actually I mean the
pot kept on stirring instead bring you
know that was another recent case in
another city in Luzerne which is quite a
famous destination in Switzerland but
there was actually a dentist the Swiss
dentist we've used to operate on patient
the patient happens to be a Muslim woman
and she refused to give him a handshake
because you know it's it's just a thing
she doesn't do right he refuses to
operate on her because he is argument
awesome you know a patient a doctor
relationship is based on trust if the
trust is not there I cannot buy the best
bill and buy the best capabilities of my
conscience I cannot operate on her you
know and of course that this has you
know blowing up again you know and like
people asking like having you made
something like a Hippocratic oath or
something you know and he said like yes
I did buy the only council with them
with emergencies you know and it's and
and she can choose whoever doctor she
actually wants you know right this
actually the same the safety interesting
in opposite positions you know I mean
yeah it has screwed there's no answer
right so this is like with us you know
it's like these bakers that don't want
to bake a cake for a gay wedding and
it's like what should the role of the
government be and should we force people
to do all this stuff so one of the other
things that you wanted to talk about
was the amount of Americans that are
moving to Switzerland so that's a
different type of immigration that you
have going on there yeah yeah you can
see the other side of the story - yeah I
mean of course the amount of American
steel pales in comparison to the EU
which the most people eventually succumb
from but they are quite a lot of
Americans coming here because
Switzerland supplies well is home to
many major global companies of course
eventually the kachoris to call my ear
and lend themselves an extract program
after someone else they can go back and
most of my co-workers actually decided
to stick around a little bit longer
because they don't appreciate the high
wages and the security and nice
infrastructure and under before sound
too optimistic too positive the
buzzwords of course there are some bad
things here as well you know like that
the depressive Sunday's here where
everything is closed right and the heart
of the high cost of living but usually
they like the social security networking
around and like to stick around here and
I thing is I have to tell you a little
story sorry about that we are also a
household where we speak a couple of
languages right and we speak also
English before my daughter answered the
king the god and she actually we had to
fill out the form explaining how good a
German was actually so he older so she
can keep up in the school you know I was
just actually yeah it's it's a sensible
thing to do and after the salient letter
I received from the Department of
Education I received a letter an angry
letter actually demanding for me to
organise that German classes and of
course I was actually surprised i asked
i was calling up i'm asking what's the
reasoning behind this because i do speak
Swiss German pretty well actually
that being said these things from
someone and she actually was very
surprised like oh yeah you know I'm
sorry by that I mistook you for someone
else because you know there are some
people who have more issues and I've
thought about that yeah I my name Paige
you know maybe she thought about Asian
people who do actually have some
difficulties Linux was too bad and she
told me actually nowhere I thought
you're American
the American she told me in private of
was the American how long those people
have most difficulties winning people
they have most difficulties and to want
to do in Swiss German actually because
one of the reasons it is because they
just spent they're just gonna be here
for five years and the others is just
that reviews because that's not what she
said no it's like yeah that's actually
no need for us to know you know because
you can also all speak English what is
actually true most people actually in in
in the area I live do speak English
phones it's actually you know the the
reverse thing of the whole thing you
know I mean it's like of course not all
the Americans for me to have many
friends in America they look like these
funds as a fine balance than my
surroundings so probably for sensitive
because that afternoon on no I mean this
whole thing interesting thing though and
after learning more about this I really
found out that there is really something
some with some Americans here and not
willingness to let himself assimilate
you know based and after asking them
after calling up my ex-employee who
happens to work with the Office of
statistics he said my guess because you
know like M there was something like not
all of them of course we don't but I
don't have something like s that just
don't like syndrome you don't like
something like that yeah we do it all
well anyway you can speak English so why
should I you know right and that's
that's really fascinating because it
also shows that this all this
integration stuff and immigration stuff
and migrant stuff it's not just about
religion its culture because now you're
telling me that Americans are coming
there it's not because of religion that
they're not integrating but it's partly
language only gonna be there for five
years there used to always speaking
English listen we could go on way longer
and I didn't get to half of it we I
didn't get to half the stuff I wanted to
talk to you about but we gotta go so I
thank you very much all right I'm on
with Stefano's from Greece Stefano's
how's it going everything is all right
here and as long like I said previously
as long as I have still money in the
bank
despite the capital controls being
implemented yeah you can still live
alright so that seems like a sort of
depressing but good place to start so we
don't hear much about Greece in the
American media but you guys are going
through a massive financial crisis right
now so I know I know you're not an
expert in economics but can you sort of
lay it out just what the average person
in Greece is going through right now
so let's just say that the minimum wage
here is 500 euros okay and so me one one
household they can live like that that's
all so to me it's impossible you can't
do that and I can say fine
it's 500 euros but can you at least ask
me slightly less but no yeah thanks a
lot more atoms that we are they're being
imposed by Merkel in the rest of the EU
officials we have to pay like we have
pretty much the taxation of Germany and
the wages and benefits of Uganda right
so basically your guys because of the
conditions that the EU helped Greece out
with your taxes are very high and you
have a lot of people that are getting a
lot from the government so there's not a
lot to go around is that pretty much
fair to say yeah it's not only the
useful the number one the ones
responsible for this in my opinion is my
government this reason and an end
government that we have right now and
they're the ones before them new
democracy for example PASOK etc so
they're responsible for this yeah so how
do you feel I mean in general
look democracy came from Greece modern
philosophy came from Greece Greece has
given so much in terms of freedom and
free thought to the world how do you
feel about what's happening in Greece at
the moment yeah if only that existed
here because it's a Padma 16 extinct
species by now
and the problem here is that let us see
the elections the elections here are
being held by a company called singular
logic that works with a government to
count all the votes etc so at the
surface it's all fine and dandy and if
you get to realize that this company it
belongs to the earth science know the
ones the big bad bankers which be honest
they and are in there I think behind the
scenes of all this nonsense right so you
guys are sort of caught between the
European Union and the bankers that are
kind of funding in the election sort of
yeah they're the ones benefiting from
these crisis yeah all right let's let's
get away let's get away from politics
for a minute because it obviously can be
pretty sobering one of the things you
wanted to talk to me about was gamergate
which a lot of people jumped on the
gamergate idea anything specific on
gamergate or how did you get involved in
it were you in it from the beginning
hey I was revolting the moment I heard
about the story of zoe quinn having sex
with one of the the journalists in
Kotaku when he posted a review of was it
the president quest if i'm right yeah
that game so it is quite obvious that
the all this gaming journalism websites
are corrupt and they all these feminists
the sjw's and all these people defend
this like when we defend this they don't
care about gamers about us so that
that's why I was so interested in
gamergate even before you know I used to
be a gamer like in the like 80s and 90s
and now like I love the culture around
video games but I don't play that much
but I thought the whole thing was
fascinating because you guys were
dealing with so much of the stuff that
we talk about now the gamers were
dealing with all the social justice
warriors stuff all the collusion between
no creators and the publishers and all
of that and feminism and all of this
stuff and that's sort of seeped up into
society which is a good transition for
you also want to talk about cultural
Marxism and I think that's very much
related so how is cultural Marxism the
ideas of it taking root in Greece right
now say that Greece pretty much invented
cultural Marxism really due to the fact
that we have parties like syriza and to
an extent of their parties like others
here which is not in the parliament
right now they get like 1% of the vote
or something and there are radicals and
there was also PASOK also known as the
Socialists which was responsible for the
Crescent we live right now like they
were promising to the people things that
on the surface are needed like high
wages high pensions benefits and all the
good stuff but what they do what they
did
let's say during the 80s they tripled
the wages so that's fine but they did it
while not acknowledging that in order to
do that you have to take some counter
measures as well like you have to
decrease taxation for the company so
that they can pay the employees and they
didn't do that unless the result a lot
of interest industries that we had back
then like we used to create buses for
example we had a car industry long but
still very relevant at the time and as a
result they all closed down and the
situation was getting worse and worse
until now that when we happened to be in
the EU and despite the things that were
being told by the media that oh my god
the EU is our home and if we live will
turn into North Korea
it's [ __ ] laughable how am I supposed
to take you seriously
to seeing this so basically the problems
that we have have pretty much have gone
+10 right at the moment we joined the EU
and the eurozone in 2001 I think mm-hmm
so when I guess it was about a year ago
when the financial crisis seemed to be
at its worst right before the EU came in
and bailed out again but you're saying
this is a pretty crappy situation but
what was it like like when you couldn't
go to the ATM and get money out didn't
they stop money coming up like what did
that feel like for you and for your
family when it feels like the system is
like collapsing it's it's very difficult
the fact that you had to take only 60
euros per day from the ATM and yeah we
can to adjust yeah that all right listen
we could talk about so much we went we
went pretty heavy here listen where's
the best place for Tsubaki in Athens
there are several restaurants where you
can buy gyros no that but I can really
tell each itália to you but one warning
yeah if you see gyros that have like a
lot of olive oil avoid it stay away from
the gyros with a lot of olive oil
all right well Dinah they they said at
least to me fair enough
all right Stefan deserves a pleasure
talking to you thanks man